today we're gonna be pitting cats versus
dogs to answer the age-old question who
loves their owners more all right so
we've got cat people we've got dog
people we are going to have everyone lay
dead in order to find out which pet is
more capable in a simulated emergency
all right my dog's name is Lucy she's
five years old and perfect
[Music]
hello my name is Nadia and this is
Steven Steven is a Russian blue kitty
cats make the best
[Music]
hi I'm Kelsey
I would dog mom of my lovely Chewie here
Chuy's a four-year-old mini golden
doodle he likes peanut butter a ton and
he hates people talking in the hallway I
just think that dogs are the best pets
[Music]
hello my name is Irish ketone and I am a
cat daddy
this here's Toulouse yes she is named
after the Aristocats Toulouse mostly
like sleeping
I believe that cats are the superior
pets
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up I'm a day and I am the
step dog father to this little dog named
max I acquired him in a relationship
he's 11 years old but he has the energy
of a little puppy hi my name is Chrissy
and I'm the proud parent of my cat
Keisha TCS six years old she loves
grilled chicken
she likes meowing at birds outside the
window I've had Keisha for a year and a
half now and she's the absolute apple of
my eye
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is Vivian and I have a dog
roomie his name is Bentley and he's my
roommate
Natalie's dog he's 11 years old in a
really big white fur ball
hey I'm Matt I am a cat parent to an 11
month old kitten named mouse he loves
sleeping he loves chasing my other cat
he is afraid of a garbage truck but he
is my friend he sleeps with me every
night hangs out with me while I work and
I'm pretty sure cats are the best pet
[Applause]
hi I'm Michelle I am a dog mom
my girl is sue she is a seven year old
she bunny we adopted her when she was
about three years old and I think she's
just like the most show but sassy dog
all the same time
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name's Tracy and I have two cats
one is named Genji she's about six years
old
and she is so sweet and cuddly and just
the prettiest cat you've ever seen and
then I have another cat named mochi and
he's about two or three and he is the
troublemaker of the family
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
so I can't say I'm too surprised that
kisi I didn't react I know that she
loves me she just shows it in different
ways I definitely think that dogs love
harder I think it takes a pretty special
cat to to on its best day rival a dog
you know your your body's lying on the
ground and cats gonna eat it that's just
the way it is
[Music]